check this out welcome to the world of
wireless charging where power is
transmitted through the air soon we
could all get rid of our power cords no
wires it's not magic but magnetic
resonance all the work happens here
they'll be very curious if alex Cruzan
explains he's CEO of white Christy
outside of Boston Massachusetts
his goal get rid of these power cords
right I mean look we we carry around
cords - you know charge up our phones we
have you know these big nasty adapters
and long cables - to power our notebooks
so word around we're going to just get
rid of them those cords were placed by
magnetic coils inside our gadgets at the
cost of just a few bucks says bruising
will show that the power his white Rissa
teased demo transmitter and receiver
helped to explain when the first powers
up it energizes the second several
devices can charge at a time as fast as
when they're plugged in how safe is that
well these magnetic waves really don't
interact with the human body at all in
fact you probably would get a bigger
dose of sort of these magnetic waves
from using a hair dryer you can do
through the head right can do it through
the head oh yeah but I'm not getting
fried you're sure I'm positive this is a
wireless desktop there's a power source
that's been built underneath so we bring
the laptop in if the charging indicator
goes on
so we've built the source into the
console so it's just as simple as
putting the phone in the console and it
begins to charge in this system there's
a transmitting coil which is in this
black pad here this would sit on the
floor of your garage there's a receiving
coil that would go on the bottom side of
your vehicle right you would drive into
the garage you sort of just hang up
there and then and then it would turn on
in fact Toyota aims to bring one of the
first wirelessly charging consumer
products a car to market by 2016 the
company is one of several investors
including Taiwan tech giant Foxconn
Chinese home appliance company hire and
Intel our first focus is actually to go
drive on no wires future snap the
transmitter into place the semiconductor
maker says it'll debut a wirelessly
charging PC type device later this year
followed by partnerships
it's like Marriott emirate airlines
Hilton to go start deploying wireless
charging solutions at the hotel at the
lounges in the airport all leading to
that big question for why tricity when
will this be reality I think within five
years all consumer electronics use
wireless charging and as the Internet of
Things grows all around us the needs of
power everything does as well and why
tricity could be the answer with
wireless power